Ah
[Music]
Printer chu no ace,
so strong son to a
tower in siem stacked or
a
very
tense 5
[Applause]
Oh, oh,
I’ve liked swords this much since I was little.
The insurance chief is directing it.
[Applause]
So
, in principle, we do not use mechanical dragons and do it with labor, which is the old-fashioned [music] for iron
.
[Music]
Physical problems Chemical problems already
exist.
Then we need air,
so when 3 comes out from there,
[music]
So it goes up and now it takes a big shape
Our traditional knife
becomes a work of art and a craft, but isn't the
original purpose of learning a tool?
Look at this disconnected
story 100 years nz The
thing that’s been safe is our Korean painting, now it’s coming out Ugh
we
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah, the
whole thing is just right Everything is
strong When everything collapses
Check it out like this Continue to be shocked and
come until a little while
I ate it, but the one I made is fine, but I
don't care
aa It's a
very one-sided story Now that's
right,
it's because there's something soft in it
Okay, it almost
happens in that
[music]
so it's the knife to balance and harmonize
that
[music]